the Prime Minister Rishi sunak is
expected to face more questions about
Nadeem sahari's tax Affairs when he
faces sakistama in pmqs today the
conservative peer and pollster Lord
Robert Hayward is with us now please
nice to see you good morning to you um
so let's start off with Nadeem zahawi a
lot of pressure on him uh the
investigation has been launched what's
the best thing for him to do at this
point do you think I think we don't know
what the time scales are for the inquiry
and I think that's key
um I think he should be considering
whether he stands aside for the periods
of the inquiry
um but the significant thing was the
other day it was said that
additional information had come out not
absolutely clear what that reference to
is but also it's interesting in the
papers this morning there's a question
mark as to whether the Civil Service
should have drawn certain information to
the attention of the Prime Minister and
in terms of ministerial appointments so
it's confused but needs to be clarified
yeah which is why the investigations
and his decisions uh you're kind of
echoing there what Caroline noakes said
about him perhaps standing aside
removing the distraction and letting the
thing run its course and him not being
in the front line I think there's a
difficulty where you are party chairman
because you're out there you're supposed
to be out there motivating the
campaigners in preparation for key local
elections in a few months time with the
main uh next hurdle for the party and
under those circumstances it's somewhat
difficult for that if you were another
cabinet minister it may be somewhat
easier to continue but I think that is
the problem for him and he may have to
review his position depending on the
time skills yeah well and we'll move
actually on to some of the challenges
facing the party but I do want to go on
to the Simon case stuff now and the
cabinet secretary as you mentioned
there's some reporting the papers this
morning that perhaps he knew and should
have informed obviously soon I can list
for us when a short-lived tenure about
Mrs zahawi and the issues around his tax
Affairs I mean what questions does he
have to answer and when will that happen
does that well that's probably one of
the biggest most complex aspects is the
time scale both of the events and also
this inquiry
um it needs to be quick for everybody's
sake if it's going to take too long it
just drags on and on for and that just
leaves everything up in the air and you
have to take a different set of
decisions but I and I think people
within the party and public at large
would want it to be a very quick inquiry
yeah I mean the cabinet secretary has
come in for criticism in the past
obviously was around during the the
party Cape uh Shenanigans let's call
them um so there will be questions for
him to answer won't there there will be
and it's very difficult politicians can
defend themselves civil servants are in
a much more difficult position because
they generally don't comment they don't
get involved in public rows but they
will have to answer the questions in
these circumstances to the inquiry
excuse me
chance to formulate my next question
um so
let's let's think about out the impact
that this is having you mentioned those
local elections coming up in May the
conservative party chairman who's meant
to be the attack dog for the for the
government out there trying to raise
money and get the message across how
damaging is it for the party right now
that there's this Scandal I mean let's
not forget as well the Boris Johnson
situation with Richard Sharp let's deal
with the first time and then I'll
comment on the on the other one
um it's not damaging at this stage it's
difficult because we are still quite a
way away from the local elections but if
we if it looks as if the timing of this
inquiry is going to run and run then it
does become damaging in relation to
Boris Johnson's issue I think that is
actually probably more difficult for
Boris Johnson rather than for the Prime
Minister because there's this constant
beat from certain people saying oh Boris
would have done it better we'd be better
in the opinion polls and actually this
highlights all the reasons that the
conservative MPS got rid of Boris last
summer I you know odd things did with
their meetings where was the money who
said what to whom we can't be certain
um what one might describe as typically
Boris events and therefore I think that
is more damaging to Boris and to anybody
just kind of problems following
following the man around I mean you
would have seen some of the polling in
the um the mail over the weekend saying
that even if he was to come back the the
labor lead doesn't actually diminish at
all absolutely and I think that's what's
happened over the last few weeks is that
as time's gone on the need for Boris to
come back is diminishing within the
conservative party and I think the
events of this weekend probably just
knock that even further now you say that
What's Happening Now isn't damaging it
it can it's a problem but I mean I guess
the point is the damage has already been
done to some extent to the party by all
the things that happened in the past few
years it has the Tory polls slumped
dramatically last summer into the Autumn
when Richard is as bad as it can be so
it's not going to get much worse no I
was going to say what happened was that
the polls started climbing back when
Rishi became prime minister then the
series of strikes have basically aborted
that rise and pushed it back somewhat
and the events that we're watching now
add to that and just cause the Tory
party to Flatline
which they wouldn't want they want to
carry on Rising towards the local
elections
how much of what's Happening Now kind of
reminds you what happened to Mr Majors
government in in the 90s
very different in some ways because that
was very much an economic series of
events from within this country one's
looking you were discussing Ukraine
you've got the question of kovid you've
got the question of strikes so there are
similarities but there are differences
and I just make the point tomorrow end
of the end of it sort of an era of
government of one party oh yes there's
no question that the balance of
probability is against uh the governing
party being re-elected so what Rishi and
the government wants at this point is a
consistent period of calm so that they
can actually get the message of
competence coherence Etc across yeah
well we've got pmqs coming up later I
mean it's always entertaining especially
because we see this new matchup Pascal
Louise he hasn't done that terribly even
though maybe I misstep last week saying
he had no issue to win the team well he
at that stage said what was probably the
case yeah but I think one of the
interesting things things which hasn't
drawn the attention is the Tory party
has been mired for 12 months probably
actually 18 months if you go right back
to the Owen Paterson Affair and actually
Kia starma has failed to score any
number of times I've sat here other
people have said prime minister's
question time will be interesting with
the expectation that KIA starma will
score at some great goal because it's
open to him and he's actually failed
he's the last majority of circumstances
and that's actually why he's got a
problem in the polls as well as Rishi
sunak and the conservatives I thought I
would appreciate your analysis this
morning thank you very much for being
with us okay